each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available uh it's a great pleasure to
welcome Brad carp he's an old friend of
mine and many of you know him he has
done a bunch of work on many different
things is yes the most famous work that
he has done was geographical routing uh
now he has ventured into other areas one
of this is this is Javascript security
work um it's got a lot of attaction
people in Google and Firefox as you can
see are interested and um he's going to
talk about that today y thanks
ch um well thank you all for coming and
thank you to uh whoever's out there
watching online uh for coming uh as jitu
says I'm Brad karp and I'm going to talk
to you about uh privacy for web
applications today today and I'm going
to mostly talk to you about it privacy
is a huge problem and there are many
many layers of uh the sort of software
and Hardware stack for the typical
browser user so I'm not going to be
talking about something that is
comprehensive about all the layers of
the stack for example I will not be
telling you what to do about bad USB
today even though while you're using a
browser bad USB could own you I'm be
focusing on the web architecture and the
browser architecture and JavaScript in
particular today okay uh so what is this
thing they call the web um well uh it
used to be in the good old days that the
web was just a way of putting documents
online if you really wanted to get fancy
maybe you'd have some links to a few
things um it was hypertext it was very
cool um and uh one of the things I find
amusing personally is that some of the
most hardcore konel hacker kind of
people you can think of in the systems
area have the most basic web pages
possible there's almost an inverse
correlation not to pick on anybody in
particular um so the web has evolved
from being just simple pages of static
content to sort of pretty complicated
and featureful applications that we sort
of rely on on a daily basis and so of
course as you all well know web pages
contain JavaScript code and when you
visit a web page containing JavaScript
code the browser just downloads it and
executes it and so I'd like to claim
it's not really a contentious claim I
hope that one of the reasons that web
app applications have been such a great
success is that it's really easy to
build web web applications and that's
because you could sort of say that web
applications are the apotheosis of Open
Source like the code has to be
downloaded to the browser at least the
JavaScript code for the client side and
so that means anybody out there who runs
that web app at Le can totally see what
the uh JavaScript code is for
implementing that browser side
functionality and they can steal it
borrow it repurpose it and reuse it and
this is exactly what people do it's
really easy to reuse code from existing
web applications because of the way the
web works and so you wind up with these
web apps that are sort of pastias you
sort of Cobble together little fragments
of JavaScript and libraries some more
modular than others from other sites but
interestingly they're written by other
parties even if you're developing a web
app yourself you often Cobble together
code written by other
parties and so once you say that you're
going to be running web
applications uh that you're going to be
using Code written by other parties
maybe we should pause a moment just to
think about privacy right so obviously a
lot of these applications you use handle
data that you would consider sensitive
maybe your bank statements your location
your email um and of course yeah this is
something the the fact that you use a
bunch of library is potentially R by
third party developers unique to the web
yeah is it unique to the web no it's not
absolutely not there's open source
software right and so there are like
third party librar that people use all
the time in open source software so I'm
not claiming that this is the first time
there's been open source libraries I'm
simply claiming that it is the in every
web application it is sort of the norm
almost required that there's a bunch of
Open Source on the on the browser side
which is not true for other
applications well in the web though
you'd be sourcing those libraries from a
third party host which has the ability
to change those things right correct
that's different from you know from
correct and that will come up later in
the talk as well in fact um actually
although you don't have to Source from a
third party you could also host it on
your own site right right right
right so uh so this JavaScript developer
of course could be
malicious um right so uh the user
doesn't know any of these developers who
wrote the third party code and you know
if you asked a computer science
undergraduate was it advisable to run
programs presented to you by parties you
don't trust they'd probably say no of
course browser does it without asking
you every time you visit a website um
and of course even in a single running
browser you visit multiple sites in
different tabs right this is commonplace
and one binary that you're running so
many of you are web architecture experts
already and so this is a broad audience
talk so I apologize for boring you for a
couple of slides as we sort of work up
to where we want to get okay um so
here's a quick example that's very
relevant in London where I live which I
call bad weather and it goes like this
you're running a browser you have a
couple of tabs open you visit your bank
account looks like things aren't looking
so good long term there and you visit a
weather website this was obviously not
for London um and you are uh browsing
these two tabs at the same time uh and
one thing you might ask yourself is if
the developer of weather.com is not a
nice person so no third party at least
with respect to weather.com itself just
the first party who wrote weather.com
put some bad JavaScript in the
weather.com page so what's to stop
weather.com from just reading your bank
statement and from Chase.com and leaking
it and sending it to the guy who wrote
the code for weather.com and runs the
server so of course as you all
presumably already know in the beginning
there was the same origin policy and
what this said um was that we'll have a
rule a policy baked into the browser
that if there's code inside weather.com
and it was retrieved from the origin or
you might just think of it as a domain
name weather.com we'll say that that
code is not allowed to read from data
from other Origins either inside the
browser or from other servers in fact
from other Origins right same or origin
policy um so not from the server
chase.com um and in fact chase.com is
not allowed to read from weather.com
either right and so the same margin
policy in brief just says that you
disallow cross origin reads between
contexts what's a context it's a tab but
contexts are also hierarchical inside of
a tab you could have an iframe there
other constructs in the browser
architecture that are contexts for
browsing and so of course this is a form
of uh discretionary Access Control right
you have a a decision about yes or no
you can either read something in which
case it's yours and you can do whatever
you want with it thereafter or you can't
read something and that's it you just
can't read it ever right so what's
interesting about this same origin
policy is that you can quickly show that
at least the way browsers use it it's it
sort of fails at opposite ways at the
same time it's both too permissive and
too restrictive some of the time it lets
things happen that shouldn't happen and
some of the times it keeps you from
doing things that You' really like to do
that would be very useful um so for
example it's too permissive um if you
have thirdparty code so we're not saying
first party JavaScript in a site now
third party that you took from from
somewhere else if there's malicious
third party code that the Barkley's Bank
didn't know was malicious and they
included it in their site saying a
script tag then if you enclose
JavaScript code in a page that third
party code runs with the Page's
Authority right and so this means that
actually that malicious JavaScript could
read bank statement data from inside the
page and leak it to say evil.com there's
nothing disallowing that in the SOP so
it's too permissive but it's also too
restrictive right s it would be really
nice if you want to build mashup
applications to be able to read data
across Origins so for example you might
have a third party who under their own
domain name wants to publish a useful
web application like something like
Quicken the web version of this exists
it's called mint right recently acquired
by
int um and so what you'd like to do is
be able to render in the browser graphs
of sort of all of your expenses and how
you've been spending your money
integrated from all of your bank
statements from the different credit
cards and bank accounts that you have
right so this is what Quicken used to do
on the client side as a binary
application mint.com doeses it on the
web and it turns out that when mint.com
if they wanted to write this in
JavaScript and why shouldn't they be
able to they just can't because uh the
same origin policy will get to more
complicated things than the SOP in just
a moment doesn't let code from mint.com
read from Origins chase.com or hsbc.com
so we just can't can't write the
application and have it run yeah but
fundamentally I don't want to pick you
too much but it's not obvious that
client side composition is what they
desire because of the lack of any sort
of Integrity enforcement on the client
in the first place so typically who
desires Sor which.com so these days all
of this composition happens serice site
and the client gets I'm going to talk
about what happens today in just a
moment but yeah um so sorry I I don't
follow what is the thing that mint
doesn't want they're worried about
integrity client side Integrity is not
something that is supported by today's
browsers sure so it's not obious so it's
supported by the system I'm going to be
telling you about today that's our work
in addition to secrecy
but okay uh but it's not obvious that
you know they're kind of they have a
burning desire to have everything on the
client in terms of composition okay so
I'm going to be talking about some of
the downsides of the way mint from the
user's perspective is implemented today
which I'm sure you already know um so
you know it's not just what mint wants
but it's what users may want too so I'll
be talking about that in just a few more
moments yeah so I guess I was going to
ask the same question but maybe tell me
if this literally the same question
which is today the way m.com works is
that I have to give it all my
passwords.com hs.com they pull the data
on the server scrape the pages or do
something maybe they have better right
so this is part of my talk actually but
yes that's what they do and I would
sayong with sorry and you say there is
something wrong with it and I say that
my releasing my credentials to my bank
accounts to a third party sucks right
yeah
um
so of course people saw that this same
origin policy failed in a variety of
ways early on and so they keep making
these Band-Aid fixes to the same origin
policy one after another as the browser
evolves over time um so these uh that
are most commonly used are cores and C
CP talk about CSP first CSP is content
security policy and it's a way of
tightening the SOP and making it more
restrictive than it would be by default
and the way that this works roughly
speaking is in one bullet that a server
uh can Whit list Origins to which a page
can send
requests okay so you can explicitly uh
whitelist some Origins and so wait I'm
whitelisting but that's why is that
tightening well because the things that
you don't whitelist by default will now
not be able to be contacted by the page
so if there's malicious JavaScript in
chase.com and chase.com doeses not
explicitly Whit list evil. Biz then even
if chase.com included malicious
JavaScript in a script tag the script
would be prohibited from leaking to
evil. Biz right okay then there's cores
cross origin resource sharing which is
sort of the complement in a way to CSP
it lets the server say that it wants to
loosen the same origin policy by
whitelisting different Origins than the
servers origin that can read from the
page okay so for example uh if you
wanted to implement mint maybe for some
reason hsbc.com would whitelist mint. CC
because they wanted their Bank customers
to be able to use mint on the bank
statements from HSBC and maybe Chase
would say no way I'm not up for that um
in fact most banks would say no way I'm
not up for it because banks are worried
about liability of what happens to data
that they send over the internet to a
customer um in fact banks are also well
banks are worried about fraud and all
kinds of other things that could hurt
the bank um in at least in the model
where Banks bear the cost of fraud um
which may or may not continue I'm told
um so uh okay so all of this is still
discretionary Access Control right yeah
so um can you tell us a little bit about
how these extensions came about like
were did somebody design these and then
go argue for them in ITF or did they go
convince Chrome or iie or some sure so
so it's just what you would expect which
is not very pretty so um you know we had
a browsing architecture we had the same
origin policy people found that web
developers found and browser designers
found that there were certain kinds of
applications or certain kinds of
vulnerabilities that they didn't like
the w3c had working groups that started
talking about some of these things with
browser vendors and then there's a
standards process at
w3c w3c can't force browser vendor to do
things but you know there's some
decision process just as if the ITF
creates a standard w3c proposes a
standard and then uh browser vendors
decide if they're going to implement it
based on whether they feel like it
really matters enough whether it's worth
their resources and so on that's my
understanding of how we got here
basically I think in some cases it was
more organic like for instance the fact
that images can be sourced from domains
interchangeably I think that's just kind
of something that came up in the '90s
right CU that's how people want
Imes were relatively huge at that
point right so sorry the question you
were asking was about these things what
I described was how these things came
about other things are completely ad hoc
and just sort of came about because
somebody thought it was a good idea at
some point
um so the question is so this is all
still discretionary Access Control
though so is this good enough we have
more flexible discretionary Access
Control well I would argue no it's still
not good enough
and so let me try to give you a couple
examples of why this is the first
example is one I've already alluded to
which is third party mesh UPS so
consider mint.com this is what you guys
were already talking about just a moment
ago how does mint.com work today and
what might be some of the reasons why it
works that way today um so mint.com
makes you pretty graphs of how much
money you're spending um and uh today
the browser can't support a secure
thirdparty mashup version of mint.com
why well let's talk about why so if you
have a choice basically what
discretionary Access Control getes you
is a choice
between uh functionality and privacy it
literally forces you to choose only one
in some situations like this so in the
case of
uh
privacy if banks decided that they were
not going to allow cores overrides to
let mint.com read dat data from Chase
and
HSBC then well that's strong privacy but
no mint.com app for the user on the
browser side right so no functionality
yes privacy or the uh if cores allowed
mint.com JavaScript to read from the
banks then you'd wind up with
functionality you'd be able to run
mint.com in the browser but of course
where the horse has left the barn right
now the JavaScript hosted by mint.com
has your data from your Banks and
there's nothing stopping it from sending
that data elsewhere or to mint.com
server yeah is in there Middle Ground
where you use you put each Origins
content in frames and then you allow
each uh origin to control the content
inside of its own frame and then if uh
two frames want to communicate if have
use post message yes so it seems like
there's sort of like this third ground
which you know allows for example
chase.com to control what graphs it
shows in its own frame but then m.com
can't directly poke it it and say like
you know give me your sensitive
JavaScript heator I see and so which
code is mint contributing to this in
this model that you're talking about
like what scripts is mint running yeah
so it's unclear right so this is why
it's kind of a middle ground because in
this case mint could for example query
each one of those frames you know what
are you willing to disclose you know
could you display this right but mint
doesn't actually get the Mandate that
and so uh that's that's just one thing
to think about because in part people
already try to use frames as these sort
of isolation this reason but you're
exactly right that it's sort of you know
the aggregator has this very we control
over what the app does asking for favors
B right so if mint wants to make sure
that its app works they sort of
supplicate to the frames owned by Chase
and HSBC in your model another
interesting question is who's in control
of the data whose data is it is it Chase
or is it me if I'm Chase's customer if I
decide that I want to run the Mint app
um so um
right so in reality as Jitsu already uh
described uh what mint does is it just
asks all its users for their Bank login
credentials and it pulls them to mince
servers um and you might say oh God
nobody would ever do that what a
terrible idea well mint has over 10
million users which is why into it just
bought them um so I believe and I think
many people should believe that this is
an abysmal model for
privacy
um okay so this was actually a somewhat
more complicated example of why
discretionary Access Control might not
be sufficient let's just give them a
simpler example that was one that comes
up a fair bit um lots of people uh
incorporate thirdparty libraries into
their web apps right and so a big thing
that people want to do since passwords
suck so much is have a password strength
checker on their website when you sort
of uh create a password it gives you a
green icon if the password's considered
good and a red one if it's considered
weak so if Chase wants to integrate uh a
script from sketchy U which does
password strength checking today um you
know Chase has the password right uh
that you typed into a form there and if
it were willing to say using post
message send the password to a script
run by sketchy Ru well then sketch. Ru
has the password and you know it's all
over at this point right so that's
that's what would happen today pretty
much um but are there real cases of
large companies using untrusted services
or in this matter I mean the previous
example there's jQuery for example
jQuery is used by 77% of the quantcast
top 10,000 sites actually don't people
typically put JY code in their
website like post or or rather use the
Google CDs actually wait stop why does
it why does it matter right I don't
understand why one's better than the
other if it's pulled from
jquery.js on their website do they like
audit all of jQuery that's the same
atast
enough people are using wait a minute
but that doesn't mean it's not a problem
enough people are using jQuery that if
jQuery starts sending random stuff to
random places uhhuh it's so we shouldn't
worry about it no that's not not what
he's saying I I'm saying with with any
right with any untrusted code right
there's part of the safety you get with
jQuery is safety and numbers lots of
people are using it which means lots of
people are also debugging with it trying
to figure out what the heck's going on
when they're using it that's right so
and enough people have problems with it
they have to go in and look at the code
to figure out what the heck's going on
sometimes so if you do download if if
you run it off the site yes if the
site's compromised tomorrow You're
vulnerable tomorrow if you got a copy
from a month ago you've got a pretty
good sense that you know of of the
things of the libraries you could be
using this is something where the code
is public everyone need so you know I
think we we could have an interesting
debate that I don't know if I have time
for right now about this there have been
back doors found in all kinds of
software Ware not necessarily JavaScript
software that have been deeply embedded
and lying there and nobody spotted them
and then they became active at a
particular time right I mean I'm not I
agree with you that like if you use a
library a lot of people use that's a lot
of eyes and that's the traditional open
source argument coming from a Microsoft
employee I love it but um you know uh is
that a strong guarantee no right no but
you were using the same argument right I
would argue that horse has actually left
the bun already use that lap to access
the website the laptop runs FreeBSD the
fact that it's open source is irrelevant
because you never actually probably read
the entire FreeBSD source code sorry no
um no uh what we're talking about here
is there's going to be it's just like in
any secure system they're going to be
components that you trust and components
that you don't trust so you are making a
reductio ad absurdum argument and what
I'm saying is I'm not talking about
whether I trust the operating system
code or not I'm not talking about even
whether I trust the browser binary or or
not I do sorry I am talking about it you
do trust those things what I'm talking
about is scripts that are malicious and
how to confine scripts that may be
malicious so you got to trust
something
so
um right well we're done even if the
library looks like it does the right
thing it says oh yeah that was a weak
password it's it's already gone so this
was just two quick examples um um but
discretionary Access Control actually
fails in a lot of situations I talk to
you about third party mashups and I talk
to you about uh libraries with narrow
apis like a password strength Checker um
there are other kinds of uh uh
situations where untrusted code
JavaScript could be dangerous right one
of them is you could actually have
mutually distrusting services so imagine
that you had an online document editor
and it provided code for documented
editing and then you wanted to have an
encrypted online document editor right
that um actually made sure that when
your document was stored in the cloud it
was always encrypted and so you might
decide that there was some organization
you really trusted to write the crypto
code for some reason and uh maybe you
trusted Google to write the document
editor code but not the crypto code how
would the trust work out maybe Google
doesn't Google's editor code doesn't
trust eff maybe eff doesn't trust Google
you need some kind of architecture to
sort of let you compose this code
together and still build a working
application and you can also have
libraries the password strength Checker
is an easy case the harder case is a
library with no API um or almost no API
which is jQuery uh jQuery sort of
requires you to include it in the page
in order to work um and so it has
unfettered access to everything in your
page and that's just what jQuery is you
can't use jQuery unless you're willing
to do that
um
so if we step back for a moment maybe
part of the problem is just that
discretionary access control is too
brittle as a design so all of these
things sop content security policies
cross orig and resource sharing they all
either deny access or just give up
control of the data utterly to the
reader once they allow reading um right
so even in the case where you used
frames like James was saying you still
completely give up control of the data
if the bank makes bad call and says oh
yes I trust this domain and the script
turns out to be malicious then you know
the the script can do whatever it wants
with the data after that because the
bank made the wrong call with
discretionary access control so I would
say that this All or Nothing behavior of
discretionary access control is a bad
fit for the web because the web is a
scenario where applications routinely
integrate untrusted code and we have
this unpalatable choice I described of
privacy versus functionality will my app
work or or um or can I have privacy but
not both so the challenge I'd like to
try to address in this talk is how can
we achieve both privacy and
functionality in web applications okay
so making sensitive making sure that
sensitive data is not leaked by
untrusted code but letting people build
featureful web applications on the
browser side okay so the germ of a
solution is a very old idea and computer
science is really starting to have some
gray hair as a field I realize when I
put this citation in slide but uh you
know you've all heard of confinement
Butler Lamson articulated the idea in
1973 although it's been fairly Elusive
and real systems that people use every
day the IDE in confinement is very easy
to State as a goal which is that let's
just let untrusted code read sensitive
data but prevent the untrusted code from
leaking the data right so in the
mint.com thirdparty mashup example the
fantasy version of this is yes you let
the JavaScript from mint. read all the
bank statement data and then something
maybe it's the browser core after those
reads happen somehow prevents mint from
getting outside of this brick wall and
sending anything anywhere even to the
mint.com origin right
anywhere so you could say oh well
confinement there's been a million
papers on confinement isn't this a
solved problem you know we have
confinement for Hull confinement for
Java everybody knows GIF right or uh you
could change JavaScript itself to
enforce information flow control right
there've been a bunch of papers on
adding fine grained IFC to JavaScript JS
flow and so forth um and what the
semantics the changed semantics of
JavaScript are after you make that
addition um but if you want to
practically deploy confinement in the
web browser there are some design
constraints that are pretty harsh um one
of them is that it's possible web
developers may not be willing to learn a
new language or at least many of them
they like
JavaScript um also you can't really
touch the JavaScript runtime or it's
very very hard to do so so as you
probably know the V8 JavaScript engine
for example or spider monkey they're
just in time compiled and very very
highly optimized um and in the browser
performance Wars people behave somewhat
irrationally there's sort of zero
tolerance for you know adding one
instruction on the hot path for uh
running JavaScript code because it's
going to make some table of numbers you
know go up by a millisecond and mean
you're not the fastest browser anymore
in some ridiculous
evaluation um so um people are very
hostile to adding anything at all in
functionality that's on the hot path in
the JavaScript runtime also you you got
to keep JavaScript but there are also
Concepts in place that web devs are used
to like the idea of Origins as
principles which started with the same
origin policy it' be nice if we could
keep that and um ideally you'd keep the
same in page constructs like the kinds
of things James was mentioning you
iframes pages and so on as security
boundaries which is what people already
are familiar with so the good news is if
you look at the web right but by
accident the web is a pretty good fit
for
confinement you just have to look at it
right so why might I say the browser is
hospitable to confinement browsers
already have execution contexts um
things like frame and iframes um and
isolation is enforced by the browser
across these boundaries in these
execution contexts already uh with
discretionary access control so maybe we
could enforce mandatory access control
but at a context
granularity so at a frame and iframe and
tab granularity not at a JavaScript
object
granularity and so what that would mean
is if we didn't have to mess with the
implementation of individual objects we
wouldn't need to change the JavaScript
runtime at all like we could actually
bake mandatory Access Control into the
same places in the browser that enforce
discretionary Access Control between
frames
today and it's pretty easy to add new
apis to the browser that manipulate the
content of uh context it's the so-called
Dom the document object model you can
attach policies to messages there's a
very rich substrate in place for uh
making enhancements to the browser there
so our system is called cowl it's
confinement with origin web labels and
it it draws on in some sense mostly
known Concepts but we put a lot of work
into trying to express the concepts in
the form of practical Primitives for the
web so and The Primitives are actually
very few we have a primitive of labels
which are based on web Origins uh which
are used to specify mandatory Access
Control policies say more about all of
these in just a moment we have labeled
communication which is what lets us
enforce mandatory Access Control between
contexts separate browsing contexts um
and we do this in a way that lets you uh
not have to change the existing post
message Api that people are already
familiar with and finally there are
privileges um and privileges are A
Primitive in our system that let you
express trust um and in particular where
this arises is sometimes in mandatory
access control you might want to
declassify data and decide that you can
release data without uh limiting its
propagation anymore but you would want
only trusted code to do that so a
privilege is a concept in our system A
Primitive in our system that it makes
explicit the right to declassify in our
mandatory access control system a
context can have a privilege with
respect to a label or
not yeah James so what happens when
these labels and whatnot get into the
Dom into the renderer I mean it seems
like the renderer is like this just
seething morass of evil and so for
example like can I leak things via like
CSS animation timing are you talking
about covert channels in the browser
well I mean in in the renderer side the
Dom itself so so yeah like I mean it
seems like because one thing you
mentioning earlier is that you try to
you want to try to not modify the
JavaScript engine if possible you want
try to leverage sort of these
pre-existing choke points exist in the
browser but if there are sort of these
side channels or Cort things that happen
inside the the the Dom yep then is I
mean that's exactly where attackers are
going to go right that's where they'll
go next yes um I mean I think that those
are two separate questions on some level
so what happens when the labels go into
the Dom and how does how much
implementation overhead does that I
don't mean performance overation over
effort and second of course there's
always the question about side channels
which are numerous and exotic and sure
so there are a lot of side channels and
I've got a slide talking about SL side
channels later in the talk um the short
answer is we have not Advanced to
dealing with side channels yet in this
work we're looking at closing the
enormous overt channels that are already
there what you'll speak about the Dom
like how you know labels can live in the
Dom and what that means uh We've not
really progressed there either yet so we
don't have ice a message through post
message as a label which is fine at the
time of in the J R time it's all good
yeah right then it goes it gets it out
to the dawn is there a marker within the
dawn so the context the context will
have the label this will become more
clear maybe when I talk about how we
Implement labels in just a moment but
calization okay maybe I'll ask that yeah
yeah yeah thank you um so let's talk
about how we do this since that's what
you're curious to know um for labels
every piece of data um in our system is
protected by a label and what the label
specifies uh in terms of Origins is
basically who cares about the data you
can think of it Loosely that way so for
example if there's data that's sensitive
to chase it would just be labeled with
the origin
chase.com or if there's data sensitive
to both Chase and HSBC it would be
labeled with the conjunction of
chase.com and
hsbc.com and you'd say what why why
would there be data sensit data
sensitive to both well for example if
you were running that third party mashup
for mint and you synthesized something
out of data from both that's the label
you'd wind up with notionally
so uh what does this look like servers
on their responses can set labels um in
an HTTP header um and in the browser a
browsing context whatever it is a tab a
frame uh can have a label associated
with
it how do we track labels as I've
already said Cal tracks labels at the
server and context browsing context
granularity so Pages iframes workers
servers um and one thing is that you can
lab for convenience for the developer we
let you label a message a message that
you send with post message differently
from the context in which you sent the
message yeah clarification question what
prevented that password data being
labeled as being sensitive to
e.com because it doesn't depend on who
set up the password box uh the password
box itself was let's say a jQuery
rendered box yeah jQuery could
potentially label it J is evil yeah that
password box itself could be set up so
that anything entered there is tagged as
e.com right and Chase would have no
clue uh what is the root of Integrity
yeah right so uh the the authority to
set a label in our system uh comes from
what the origin is where the content was
retrieved from but the password box was
retrieved from was rendered by a
renderer given by jQuery right jQuery
when jQuery renders like a date drop box
or something
uhuh where is so ah okay jQuery is
actually maybe I don't know if what
you're asking is specific to jQuery we
have a whole
different schema there's a different way
of dealing with jQuery in our system
that I did not describe here because it
would make my talk too long it is in the
paper so is it something about jQuery in
particular that you're asking about yeah
dynamic HML so for example the way at
least I'm not a power user I use it only
a few times right but the way I would do
this is I would set a element with ID
yeah and I would tell Jake where to
essentially replace that with a box and
you know whatever yeah so at that time
who labels that data that's what I'm
asking so what you're pointing out is
that the usage model for jQuery is that
it runs with the authority of the
enclosing page right that is specific to
jQuery password Checker libraries that
we're talking about are a different use
model where they are not enclosed in a
script tag in the page and they do not
run with the authority of the enclosing
page they're in a separate context and
this is another model that people use
JavaScript in okay so it is I Now
understand your
question I have a backup slide that I'll
be happy to I could jump to it now if
you want on how we handle jQuery
basically the answer to your question is
this if you want to enclose untrusted
code with a script tag nobody no a way
to do it but what it what it involves it
almost looks like open SSH privilege
separation what you wind up doing is you
have two compartments you drop privilege
on the one that has
jQuery and then you have a small trusted
code base running in a separate browsing
context and that's sort of a firewall
between the
jQuery context and the rest of the
network that's the sort of high level
idea but that is specific to
jQuery um and libraries like jQuery that
only work if you include them with a
script tag because they want to touch
the Dom directly
yeah okay great questions so
um label tracking was where I
was so for convenience we let uh
programmers label a message that they
send with post message differently than
the browsing different with a different
label than the browsing context it has
to be at least as restrictive as the
browsing context label but you can set
a different
label um so this turns out to be a
convenient way to share sensitive data
um so for example if
chase.com downloads a page to your
browser if your browser downloads a page
from Chase.com the initial label is what
we call public which means no
restriction think of it as the null
label Okay then if Chase wants to send
that password to a third party library
with a narrow API unlike jQuery then it
will use post message to send the
password to that library and it's free
to in the cow system set a label more
restrictive than the one of the base
page but of course browser server
communication had better respect labels
that's very important right so um we
need somehow to make sure that
um there's no way the browser would
enforce uh
that there's no way for uh code
contained in
chase.com with a browsing context with
label chase.com to send that password
from that browsing context to some other
origin right that's not desired in this
model um and communication across
browser contexts should respect labels
too right so in addition because why is
that important well if sketchy Ru is
running its Library in a
separate context that has label public
and then chase.com
context sent the password to sketchy Ru
then you wouldn't want it has to be
transitive you wouldn't want sketchy de
Ru to then be able to go ahead and send
that password to the origin that it was
downloaded from so this stuff is not
proposable using CSP I mean it seems
like CSP is designed to stop a lot of
these types like specifically these
types of flows so CSP is designed for
this kind of flow it doesn't help you at
all with third party mesh UPS so we have
two papers on this work the first paper
was a hotos paper where what we did was
we described how using mandatory Access
Control lets you do things that you
can't do with cores in CSP and it also
subsumes them so it is strictly more
General so you are correct that some of
the examples I'm giving are things that
you could do with CSP the third party
mashup is one that you cannot the
mutually distrusting document editor is
one that you cannot
so so I'm thinking about the m.com
example you gave right so presumably
here HSBC and Chase will both set their
context so that no data can ever be sent
to the m.com server and any processing
that m.com does would have we now done
on my local correct okay now m.com
provides this is a purely functionality
question m.com provides a number of
comparative Services it requires it
transmit some data back to the server
otherwise it's kind of useless actually
mhm uh wait a minute for example my rate
of return versus other people's rate of
return on certain mutual fund something
like that right I'm just making up an
example so that is now that door is
closed unless J and HSBC both allow
pretty much any dat of go to me or
unless you know you're going
to try using some of Google's new
differential privacy stuff for sending
stuff privately back from the browser
the server I don't know I mean
presumably but as soon as the mint
computes any mashup it would be labeled
as correct that's absolutely correct
absolutely correct it'll have the label
the secrecy label of HSBC and Chase
which means no one in the universe at
that point correct
so so uh if you have an application so
there is an answer to this if you have
an application uh that um okay wait so
there for the example you gave where
there's data that is derived directly
from
data that is sensitive to the user the
presumption in this design is that the
user doesn't want data derived from that
data
to be computed by a third party and
leaked anywhere no but it's Tri I don't
want m.com to have my password I don't
care so much if m.com has my bank
balance okay well there are a lot of
people who would disagree with that
statement okay well but but 10 million
users sorry wait a minute you can't just
say that it's obvious that nobody would
care that mint.com has their bankal I'm
giving you another usage example of
course other some people might care I'm
just saying that my password is more
sensitive it's a complex negotiation
because right mint.com is going to know
what stocks I own otherwise it can't go
out and get quotes for them uh and if it
can't go out and get quotes for them
then I lose functionality so okay I
don't know the browser could get quotes
for them it's not like mint needs to
know what stocks you have there plenty
of open quote services that the browser
could directly pull get but if I'm
visiting mint.com in on a slow 3g
connection on my phone now all of a
sudden there are a lot of round trips
that my browser is doing and it's so
much slower than if mint actually had
access to everything and went and did
all the work and sent me back a single
HTML page all the content I accept that
yeah these these are all cops negoti but
I think the question you asking is
what's called declassification language
based IC sounds like you don't have a
mechanism we do have a mechanism for
declassification there's there's support
for declassification but the question is
who has the authority to exercise that
that's always the question and how
correct this right exactly exactly right
speak to that well uh very briefly very
briefly case of men.com which is like at
the height of that lce there is no way
to go back it'ss like right that's
right all
right so we went through this already so
in order for this example to work of the
thirdparty password strength Checker um
we're going to need some way for the
script provided by sketch. Ru to see the
data and compute over it so the way that
we're going to do this as you do an
information flow control systems is by
having a context adopt a more
restrictive label by giving up its
ability to communicate with uh places
that should not be able to see the Sens
sensitive data it will then be allowed
to read the sensitive data okay so uh
for example sketch. Ru could receive a
post message from Chase.com with the
password in it labeled it's a labeled
post message right um with a label
chase.com it then possesses the labeled
message but the browser will prohibit it
from seeing the content of the
message okay so it knows that it
received a message but it doesn't know
what's inside then it is free to this is
important for you know it would be
inconvenient if when you received a
message your label was forced by the
browser to be raised immediately because
you just suddenly would find you
couldn't talk to the world anymore so
instead we let you have the message
labeled but you can't read it before the
browser will let you read the content
what will happen is you will need to
choose to raise your label which will
mean you'll lose the ability to
communicate with other Origins than the
origin of the label question and that
communication includes anything gets
posts puts anything yes but the presence
of a label or the presence of a message
I should say is a channel source as well
the presence of a message is a channel
we don't even let you inspect the label
um until you have raised your label
accordingly number of messages yes you
could yes absolutely right it's cover
Channel yeah so would I be able to use
this to do the stock picking example
where you know I go access Chas I'm
mint.com I go access chase.com I get the
list of uh stocks that you have and then
I use I want to use some other third
party service to go pull down stock
information for each one of those yes it
will work okay and you'll tell us how um
yes the answer is partly privilege
separation um which I'm not going to get
into that much in this talk
unfortunately um
but uh to conclude my example uh finally
the password Checker can reply with weak
it did its work it was confined it could
not leak the password to sketch. Ru and
then it returns its result back to
chase right so the sort of summary of
the design sketch is that uh Origins are
a natural way to specify labels for the
web um you can already you can Leverage
The contexts that are already there as
security
boundaries um and Origins can be used to
express privileges and this
uh has to do with declassification and
uh for time Reasons I'm not going to go
into detail on declassification on The
Talk uh basically this is how we handle
things like jQuery you need
declassification it turns out to handle
things like
jQuery
um so compromised you're still
host no incorrect because let's say
you're using text in jQuery you are
relying on jQuery to make sure that a
string uh doesn't contain any dangerous
HTML J jQuery is part of your trusted
Computing base okay so let me show you
my slide on jQuery since we're going to
go there it
appears and then I'm really going to
need to continue with my talk or I won't
complete my talk um so uh I'm not going
to walk you through absolutely all of
this the high level of this is you know
how privilege separation Works in open
SSH right great so what we're going to
do is we're going to have a site a.com
that wants to use jQuery what it's going
to do is um it's going to drop its
privilege and not have the privilege to
declassify label
a.com okay which and it's going to set
its um label uh to be a unique label so
that it's not allowed to talk to any
network anywhere no one on the
internet what we're going to do is have
a separate compartment that's where the
trusted codebase is this is not where
jQuery is jQuery is going to be
executing in the low privilege
compartment just like an open SSH right
The Trusted code untrusted code and then
what we're going to have is um basically
The Trusted code is going to download
jQuery and inject it into the Dom of the
untrusted compartment and then after
that all communication that the page
with the possibly malicious jQuery in it
wants to make to the outside world has
to be mediated by The Trusted
compartment because there's no
communication allowed to the Internet by
by force of the label so how does this
how does the text thing break through
this because when I'm using do text what
I am doing is I'm telling jQuery this is
something that could have dangerous this
is a string that could have dangerous
stuff in it I want you to to HTML encode
it so that it's safe to put in the web
page so I am using jQuery as part of my
TCB to say take this string from
something that's not safe to put in HTML
into something that is safe to put to
HTML okay but still but but the only
place jery HTML tag which is a function
that's supposed to let me put the
dangerous stuff in but jQuery is going
to inject this potentially malicious
HTML into its own frame
right it so the entire page is it a
different frame sorry I think what you
just said is text is
sanitizing right right it's a malicious
stier is what you're postulating that
does not properly stize correct
excellent so that's running here in this
low privilege
compartment
right and so now what can it do it can
like in inject more content inside of
this compartment right so the whole but
that's where the whole web page is is it
not yes using query yes but the page is
confined it's not allowed to talk to the
internet is anyone allowed to talk is
there any so in other words if jQuery
can anyone get even if that thing on the
left is sandboxed if there's a pipe that
then allows sort of the stuff that
sandbox to get to anywhere else in the
network then I think what steuart's
saying is that if the content on the
left is sandbox fine it itself can't do
anything CH what it can do is it the
only thing it will be able to do is go
through the trusted compartment and send
messages to The Trusted compartment so
the moment you open up the possibility
of an xss attack this is exactly what's
going happen they'll just follow the
that's
right to point but on the wait sorry but
you can put whatever code you want in
The Trusted compartment right to
mitigate no the point is that if you
have some xss or some malicious
sanitization it can trigger undesirable
or unexpected what have you messages to
the compartment on the right yes that's
absolutely correct just like in open SSH
when you have a monitor process somebody
can own the untrusted compartment and
send whatever rpcs they would like over
IPC to the monitor but yet we don't seem
to think that open SSH privilege
separation is
useless what you do is you very it's a
very thin connector right you've got a
very thin well-defined set of and why
could I not have a thin well- defined
thing here for the serialized
communication between that context in
this context since I designed what this
code is because uh the level of skill
for somebody working with in the code of
open SSL is probably different from that
working you know on web applications
okay so that's a I understand the
argument that you're making but that is
not an impossibility argument that is a
skill level argument just OB observation
right right right I
agree yeah um so yes like you could
craft malicious messages and send them
here I would say that that is better
than being able to send whatever you
want directly to the internet because
there is code that a potentially smart
person could have written and had
audited that is going to inspect what
those messages are and you know on some
level privilege separation is one of the
only things we have in our Arsenal
against compromise of code in
compartments and systems I
mean I'd be happy to continue this
conversation offline
um back to the
talk
all right so I'll just Breeze through
this since I think you all completely
understood how the system worked already
from the questions that you've been
asking uh we can use the Primitives I've
described to implement mint as a third
party mashup uh Chase uses post message
labeled post message to send uh sorry uh
mint.com can read labeled data from
Chase's uh context and it can read
labeled data from
HSBC however in order to actually see
the data in the messages it needs to
raise its label it would raise its label
to chase.com first which would mean it
could not talk to hsbc.com any longer it
would then raise its label to add the
conjunction uh of hsbc.com and would no
longer be able to talk to chase.com or
anyone else at that point and then it
can make you pretty graphs of how you're
spending your money um so this means
that you could now implement this mashup
uh in the browser with privacy without
giving your login credentials to the
operator of mint.com
uh example two that I used as a
motivator at the beginning of the talk
is the thirdparty password strength
Checker um and I already showed you what
that looked like actually I showed you
labeled communication with sketch. Ru um
I actually have a demo of a Chromium
browser running the password strength
Checker example and I'm going to skip it
because you've all had such great
questions so far and it's not much to
look at really
um so we built built it um we built
implementations both for Firefox and
chromium we made no changes whatsoever
to the JavaScript
engines um and uh the implementations
for Gecko and blink were about 4,000
lines of C++ each you know implementing
a label system takes a little bit of
work um and we've released the Firefox
implementation open source they're also
ready to run binaries that are there you
can give it a try at cal.
WS we tried very hard to emphasize
deployability in our design um so I just
going to keep repeating myself there
have been no changes to the JavaScript
engine in our discussions with the V8
team at Google it became clear to us
that at least at
Google to get mandatory Access Control
in the browser it was not going to
happen in
V8 um so uh it's just really three new
JavaScript Primitives um so we think
that it ought to be fairly familiar
because it uses Origins to express
policies it's fast in our performance
evaluation which the details of are in
the paper uh the worst page load
overhead we experienced using a case
that we thought was pretty punishing was
just 16 millisecs for increased page
load time why is it fast why is it this
fast well because when you're in the
Inner Loop of executing the JavaScript
code we didn't touch the JavaScript
engine right so if you've got some
hairry script that's doing a lot of
compute it runs at full speed and it's
only when you cross contexts that our
code to do label checks gets
invoked so um and it's Backward
Compatible with Legacy Pages we only
start using confinement mode when you
encounter a cow primitive in the page so
you've already brought up several of
these things already uh there are a few
things worth discussing that are
interesting one of them is covert
channels what Cal does is it closes the
gaping over channels that uh the SOP and
discretionary Access Control uh leave in
some cases um so the stock browser as
you've pointed out is r with covert
channels Cal doesn't add covert channels
but it doesn't close them
either um so this means malicious code
could covertly leak data through covert
or side channels um Cal does enforce Mac
in addition to the existing DAC however
so if you had some application where you
really felt like this was military grade
and you were worried about covert
channels um you know you could still
deny with deck in that application we
don't break the things you might like
about deck if you want them for an
application for one
application um this one point you could
make is that nobody knows what Cod
mint.com is running on their servers
right or what quality it is or how
vulnerable it is one consequence there's
lots of things you guys seem not to like
about running it in the browser from
crappy 3G connections to all kinds of
other things one good thing might be
that that um if you forced people to use
covert channels in JavaScript they'd
actually have to put the code out there
for the big things for the bad things
that they were doing which is actually a
little bit more like Stuart's argument
before that what because so many people
are using the code and everybody can see
it you know you might find out that
there's something nasty in there I want
to find a good covert channel so my code
there you go but but is there is there
demand for that like I could I could go
build secur mint.com today where I do as
much as I possibly can in JavaScript
certify to users hey you know I have I'm
not using third party JavaScript
libraries you can go go look at my
JavaScript code as there and but but yet
you know mint.com today has so many
users right so I'll talk about this in
just a couple of slides as the very last
point I want to make um another thing is
that for the jQuery example which was
more complicated than the other ones you
would actually need to you can't just
for a something like jQuery label and
run the Legacy code you would actually
need to compartmentalize into multiple
contexts that have different Privileges
and different labels and that requires
thought or to put it the way you did um
maybe the average web developer um would
find this a little bit daunting um there
are some modes of use that we think are
fairly simple there are other modes of
use that are not as simple
um okay just almost done here uh so for
discussion um who should have the last
word on policy in the browser is it the
user or is it the site
operator
so as I already said Callin forces Dak
alongside Mac so Chase might still it
might or might not set the Coors header
letting mint look at Chase's
data right given what bank it
departments are like they probably
wouldn't set the cor header allowing it
and so in our implementation as I've
described it so far that means we still
can't do the third partyy mashup because
we're upholding the Dack alongside the
Mac our view is that it's the user's
data so the users decisions should be
uppermost not the site
operators like if you want functionality
with your data you should be able to
have that functionality so what Cal in
our current implementation lets users do
is lets users in not in Kors syntax but
let's users specify what are effectively
cores rules that enable cross origin
sharing so for example a user could
configure the browser to say oh no no no
mint can read Chase's data and what Cal
will do is force all of that
communication to be labeled to make sure
that Min scripts are
confined
okay now coming back to the question
come on is malicious JavaScript really
some yeah have you I was curious whether
this Cal introduces any problems for
deing if you de the example with me.com
if you already buug that thing yeah you
know you probably want to send some data
back to m.com
that according to Cal should not sure so
after the after the after the label gets
raised it' be very very hard to send
data back.com so what's the
debugging Story how do I debug how does
me.com debugs their code on
the when something happens in deployment
in real deployment with real users
something happens when users complain
you need to start instrumenting youre to
see what the heck is going on so that is
an excellent question um and I
I don't have a very satisfactory answer
to it right now um it could be that this
sort of crash dump kind of in feedback
is just at odds with privacy to some
extent or that we need clever new
technical
means I mean so for binaries running on
the client side if the user really cares
about privacy they say don't send back
right so same
thing okay so
why are we really wasting our time with
malicious JavaScript come on right so
like attackers are so successful with
fishing already and installing malware
on browsers just because users click
okay and run binary so you know isn't
this just going another computer
security researcher going after a
problem that nobody has
right um
well jQuery was hacked
on September 18th and September
24th um it's used by a lot of very
popular
websites now as far as anybody knows
there wasn't any adulteration of the
jQuery Library when these hacks happened
there was other defacing that happened
but not of the library there easily
could have been and it's obviously a
very attractive Target because so many
people Source it from
jquery.com incident all of you I
hope right so just to review for a
moment in the by attack what happened is
BYU was hosting analytics JavaScript
right and lots of people outside of
China sites outside of China and inside
of China were using those analytic
scripts including them in their page and
it appears at least from Vern Paxton and
Nick Weaver and all those people's
report
analyzing uh the BYU attack that what
was going on was the great firewall the
same infrastructure that inspected
Network traffic at the periphery of
China uh they found another application
for the infrastructure right which is
instead of you know seeing if there's a
request for banned content and sending a
reset or a bogus DNS response you could
also have a new application which the
authors of this report I mentioned
called great Canon which is um uh if
there's something that comes in from the
global internet through the same choke
point and there's some criteria met like
is this a b do analytic script that's
being requested then just respond
immediately with a malicious script so
in the by attack what they used this for
was to Dos GitHub because it had a
software project on it to circumvent the
great firewall of China um hahaa um so
the good news is it was easy to spot the
bud dos because doses they're kind of
noticeable when they happen right but it
appears that we now have a nation that
has an infrastructure in place that it
was willing to use at least once to send
malicious JavaScript to people it
happened to be for dos in this case but
it could have been for something else
right it could have been to steal
secrets from web application users not
your password for mint.com probably but
you know there's all kinds of
interesting data and web applications
these
days was this milous japt coated with
something
else uh the malicious sorry people were
including BYO analytic scripts they used
the great firewall to see the request
and just reply with a malicious script
that was
apparently yes the request we going to
BU do and to an American website the
request goes to China for for the
analytic script yeah and then the
browser user could be anywhere of
course um of course also TLS you could
say oh well this is because you're
stupid to include scripts using HTTP and
not https TLS is not historically the
most convincing defense against State
actors either right like there's a lot
of s certificates that your browser a
lot of Casas that your browser trusts
there have been incidents of
certificates being
compromised so uh to wrap up uh
discretionary access control is what
browsers use today and in many
situations it can force a choice between
privacy and functionality and users at
least if you believe mince users choose
functionality rather than
privacy um but modern web applications
will need to have untrusted code compute
oversensitive data if people keep
building them the way they do now so
what I described to you was a system
called cow which was an osdi
2014 uh and we think it's a Deployable
confinement system for JavaScript it
introduces little performance cost and
achieves both privacy and flexibility
you can check out our open source
release and we actually are now
chartered at the w3c for cal um they're
starting to look at standardizing Cal
for uh the browser architecture as
standardized and I'd be happy to take
questions I wanted
to I wanted to follow up on your on your
previous slide where you said you know
about the state actors this whole this
whole U mechanism relies on DNS Origins
to begin with that's so fundamentally
baked into everything we talked about
that at that point you know if if your
if your if your attacker is China we're
done right if if the whole mechanism
relies on oh you just have to make sure
it goes to the same DN I mean how broken
is that so you know what I mean so in
some sense if if your threat model is
China we should
stop we should we should go back to
square zero that's how I guess my my
argument passenger Visions
bro you know so it's it's I think yeah I
think TLS here I think it's a little
unfair to say that he not the convincing
defense against the actors I think same
origin policy is not a convincing
defense against the ATT because let me
just be I want to narrow down to a very
specific attack because the attack the
the the the cost of mounting attacks the
DNS infrastructure is so low and what's
the specific DNS based attack that
you're interested in I mean I'm sure
sorry uh we're going to have to come up
with one redirection attacks for example
okay so like for example you're going to
cause me not to go to chase.com or to
you're I'm going to think I'm going to
chase.com but I'm going to download
content from some other party and you're
going to be able to convince me that the
TLs is valid or yeah I get jqu from some
you know sketchy Ru BNS makes me get
sketchu at ru's JavaScript and the same
origin policy doesn't know about that it
just knows that yes this from so what
you're saying is that once TLS doesn't
work nothing works anymore basically or
then in general if you have a system
that that binds security tokens to names
where forging names is fairly easy for
China then
you know like what what we're going to
do in other words that we can't stop
that I
see maybe this is not the best
example
yeah that you know not your fault but it
just but but I think sort it's my fault
for it's my fault for choosing the
example I struggle with all for paes but
but I mean I think that just in general
I think this is a big problem for web
Security in general because the same
origin policy is based on these like
easily spoof origin names and so as a
result it becomes very careful to say
like I mean and this is like a problem
with all the anti-censorship stuff and
so on and so forth on the web because
they're saying you know if I trust this
comes from this origin but if that name
can come from anyway y
exactly uh I wanted to ask you about R
time enforcement mechanisms and you
didn't really talk about those so the
two come that come to mind are Kaa and
conptt yeah and there different
tradeoffs between the two maybe you
can uh okay so about like where you fit
in your thinking
so if I remember correctly kaha is a
subset of JavaScript is that correct
writing for the subset you do L right
that's kind of the tradeoff I see but it
works for fully General ecma whatever is
is I'm just trying to get okay so my my
understanding from the from the Java
JavaScript nerds I work with because I'm
not a core JavaScript nerd um I'm more
of a system security person is that uh
kah is not fully General to JavaScript
maybe that's not correct general
actually I mean the overhead is bismal I
mean that's that's to my mind that would
the show stuff okay so um if kaha is
fully General then I think the
performance point would be the a
significant difference yes
um
uh to be honest I personally have not
looked at very very carefully I've
looked at JS flow I've looked at B flow
so I've looked at other IFC based
systems in the browser sorry conscript
conscript I don't know that one where's
that from I the
paper I'd be delighted big question I'd
be delighted i' I'd be delighted to look
at it yeah L ship
script one of our favorite systems
here right Oakland
2012 I'll take a
look I mean what we talk about in the
system design that I didn't get into in
the talk is that there were these design
criteria that we had which was were that
we wanted hierarchical confinement so
that you could have libraries that
didn't trust libraries that didn't trust
libraries potentially so that's one
aspect of the system that we did not see
elsewhere um B flow for example does not
have that property and the trust zones
in B flow mean that you uh can't do
third party mashups either but yeah so
um I don't know of
many um many privilege separated apps
and I find it interesting that the one
that does exist is written where the The
Trusted part and the unrusted part are
written by the same people who simply
didn't trust themselves to write
everything securely enough there's an
incentive problem in that if you're
writing your stuff not to get any
information out you're getting l out of
it um and so how do you envision this
ecosystem working so I guess what I'm
trying to figure out is the implication
of the start of your question was
because op SSH the the privileged and un
unprivileged compartments the code is
written by the same person you're
implying that in our system the
privileged and unprivileged are written
by different people is that correct well
they one's going to contain code that uh
that's written right you may part of it
will be written by
part of both is written by the trusted
and untrusted okay so hang on hang on
the part that's written by the untrusted
has to be written so that it works in
this context right you you can't plug uh
say A system that needs to send the
password to the server into uh into
something that's going to confine it um
and so uh well people people can always
choose not to use libraries that are
not it it is the choice of a developer
if they have a choice between a library
that offers some security properties and
one that does not that is a choice that
the developer makes they might make bad
choices that that wasn't my point my
point was someone has to be someone has
to have the incentive to develop the
right the the analytics library that
doesn't actually send stuff to the
server or that right it's right we
haven't
seen um in in the desk top we haven't
seen a lot of people go out and write
privilege separation uh because it's a
very specialized context where you have
to right not trust part of your code and
you're willing to make things a lot more
complicated so just to be clear I talked
about four use cases only one of them
requires privilege separation and that's
the jQuery case where you include a
library in a page as script tag that has
direct access to the Dom it's not
privileged separation in the
conventional sense for the other use
cases so so for the for the m.com right
yeah you have to have who's incentivized
to to change the way mint.com Works to
create one that's that's different so so
how's that going to take place so um
presumably there could be a company or
an open- Source developer who felt that
there was demand from users to not give
their login credentials to Banks and
they would be motiv loin credentials are
a red herring they're not a red herring
they are red herring because red what's
private is the information in the
account if if okay fair enough login
credentials and the information in the
account fine even better yes so the
information in the account they don't
want to have a third party know the
information in their account right so a
developer could decide that there's a
market for this that some users might
prefer to use an application that does
not share the contents of their bank
statements and then they would write an
application just like when what was the
market for mint saying oh I bet people
wanted to be able to look at this
information in an integrated way now you
can say that you think that no users
care so so the user is trusting so so
they're basically the the party they're
trusting to write the code not to reveal
the information in that case is the code
that gets access to the
information no because the browser
confines code we wrote the browser
they're trusting us not the people who
wrote
mint someone has to write the part that
takes in the password and then doesn't
reveal any
information no no um so you would log in
to chase the normal way in Chase's frame
right and then there would be a cookie
in your browser just like there always
is and then we would allow the cross
origin
requests from mint but mint is
confined by our system you did not type
your password for Chase into mint ever
and it does not have access to that
password again password is the so sorry
but I think you you used the word
password so I'm replying to you just
said it has to get the password from
somewhere did you
not I was replying to that now nrow
points okay um so mint no I understood
that much but but then you're saying
that that the code I let's say we'll
call it mint 2.0 y mint 2.0 writes this
it then can go and do any requests for
chase.com and get it back because
it's I think the point is that the user
can ins the C of the page and see that
I'm typing
in if you ret if data from CH it can't
it anywhere right that's the point but
the question is how the password right
user typing the password into a text
box. by Chas Chase but it could be owned
by mint.com the user knows if they look
at the source for that page and says oh
this this box actually frame from Chase
is this a usability argument you're
making no I I don't understand who's
providing the API at chase.com when it's
scraping there's an API there and but
presumably someone at chase.com has to
provide an API chase.com just sees that
it's getting normal requests for
downloading data to a browser because
you can send the cross origin request so
this is an XML HTP request yes okay sent
by
Mint sent by Mint so you first have to
the the user has to then go go log into
used are previously logged in yeah
okay um
see that that actually is my usability
for it right now I just go to m I type
in one username and password everything
is in the back of the server makes it
great poetry in motion exactly it is
otherwise I wouldn't if I had to log to
16 different size mid by the way today
gives you an option I don't know whether
to trust do you ever log into your
actual bank what do you ever log into
your bank yeah you only or you only log
into mint no I do both okay so you're
already logging no no but mint the the
idea okay so mint today I don't know how
Securities offers you an option where
they do not store your password okay
uhhuh you have to basically go and type
in whatever number of bank accounts and
stock accounts you have you to go type
in every password separately each time
you use M uhhuh and from what I've heard
just based on Mid forums nobody uses it
off right right and so and so we're
offering something easier than that but
but you still want to type all 16
password each time no no the the cookies
can be persistent question it's like you
know do you see your image and stuff
like that so like even if it's Cur so
you don't have a live session at the
moment the Contex of that right one of
the things that men use account alerts
and that's quite helpful so there's a
constant service site presence I see so
yes it's true like if the server sees
that you if Chase's server says that you
don't have a fresh session even if you
have a cookie that's valid yeah there'll
be some steps yeah that's right I also
want to ask a question about your
argument about the users should be in
charge of their their data setting up
polies so if if that's the model then
the next thing I would think about is
you know I'm men.com or or bat or
sketch. Ru just gonna basically say pop
up a or something that pop up a window
that says you know sorry if you really
want to get access to your graph you
have to press this declassifying button
because otherwise you know it's not
working properly for you
and shown that a lot of users would
click they just click okay users love to
click okay um so why is that model the
right mod so users are in charge of
certain of so users can make mistakes
the system we we have not in our system
what we are doing is letting users
whitelist but then enforcing confinement
on the code that gets the sensitive data
right so so so users are partial there's
no there's no button lets you turn off
mandatory Access Control when you click
okay in our
system so if you're worried about covert
channels no then maybe yeah cover
Channel CH yeah different so users can
only actually things make things more
restrictive not less
restrictive no they make things less
restrictive in the following sense they
turn off the discretionary access
control on Chase to let Chase's data be
seen by the script from mint.com
okay right but in our browser
make sure that the code for mint.com is
confined I see okay and there's no way
the user can turn that off okay okay how
but if you turn if the user did this uh
in mint.com without telling mint.com
wouldn't mint.com code get really
confused it's getting this response to a
message that's got its label on it the
code doesn't understand about labels it
wasn't expecting to be
confined um no just a moment so your
question is when mint sends a message to
Chase is there a label on the message
from mint so no no no
so in this other scenario the user says
I'm not going to give my password to
Mint but I'm going to just go to go to
cow and say just let mint send things to
Chase and it'll and right use use Mac to
to can find it but in in the scenario
wouldn't Min send something to Chase
Chase would say yeah here's the data and
there's and by the but it's opaque until
you you know do this play this game
where you lower your privilege uh in
order to read it you raise your label
yeah raise your label
isn't mint.com codee isn't going to know
what to do with that it's if the user
says if if if mint.com didn't change its
uh its code to deal with these these
labeled messages oh mint mint mint has
written its application to deal with
labeled messages that is our they know
about Cal they know about Cal and they
write me to I think you had a new
scenario where the user says oh for even
if the even if the my Cod the code
didn't decide to use Cal I can make
it this
is this is 2.0 yeah okay right right the
part it's it's what the banks it's
disabling the discretionary access
control of the banks the banks can be
fully Legacy or maybe not if you're
worried about the live session problem
but
um okay
I but usability like how do you assess
the usability of this and more Gra
scientific way well let's not even go
that far I mean so here's one
problem scientific so here's one you
know troubling piece of news I've been
talking to my friends of missa back and
forth the last couple of month and they
say that they've been running scans to
see how often CSP is getting used and
outside of the uh extension model which
works in Chrome and Firefox the same way
and CSP is used very well and profitable
and everything is great it's actually
not being used almost at all mhm and so
then that begs well a whole number of
questions one of which is well is it
because they not not good scenarios to
use it to use it then or is it because
the usability is not entirely there the
developer as I was pointing to go ear is
not sophisticated enough you know just
doesn't come together because you know
it's one thing to propose a mechanism
and another thing to get deployed on any
sort absolutely correct I don't
disagree how would you even go about
assessing the usability of this uh so by
releasing it as open source and talking
to web
developers I
guess's the most appliation using this
password Checker was one mint is clearly
far more jQuery the actually the
privilege separated jQuery is the most
complicated of
them you that's what you yeah we've got
it all four of those we have running
implementations of but that's good
enough no
no that's
scientific we're not third floor
marxists I go around with user studies
and Bs of
candy um there's something there right
in terms of the level of complexity the
developer expects and the level of
complexity one brings and I'm not saying
this exclusively about your proposal I'm
saying this about whole number of
proposals simpler proposals yes a whole
number of simpler proposals is what
you're saying simpler or more complex
depends on your point of view but I
think there is something uh you know
there's there's a certain degree of
mismatch because the same origin policy
you can hate it or not hate it as much
but you know it's kind of like one of
those things you grow up with right as a
developer plenty of people who hate
things they grew up with but yeah I know
I
know uh and it seems like there's a bit
of a cliff kind of thing after that
right I mean like um you know so so it
doesn't adoption is difficult so I know
don't do anything you're assuming that
developers understand the same origin
policy not assuming anything just saying
well they understand when it makes their
code not work they keep trying random
things until it does work and that's
that's a model of sorts and I'm not sure
that there's a debugging sort of style
approach to your proposal F work the
same way and again it's not the perfect
outcome one gets you know from this
approach but it's something right yeah
you talk to you talk to Brandon I will
tell you right so there was kind of a
thing for Mom and Pop you write HTML
then you go a little bit of get a little
bit of functionality you get animation
right and that's a way to go now of
course you have things that are you know
much more complicated infinitely more
complex than that but the question is
well can we use this I think it's a good
question I do think that
um if you look at the example on the
website not that you would take the time
necessarily but if you did I know you
would see that the password strength
Checker is actually not that complicated
at all like the source is quite simple
so we spend a bunch of time talking
about the privilege separated jQuery one
that's the hairy one a lot of the use
cases just a second for uh third party
libraries that have a narrow well-
defined API that's the sweet spot for
this
definitely
um
which password check use how we wrote
around